you
[Music]
all right so I guess I'll get started so
I'm a but rich Chandra naadi I'm a
researcher in the database group here at
MSR Redmond and today I'll be talking
about open source technologies for
streaming and state management from our
group focusing really on two systems
that we have built recently and open
source called trill and faster so brief
background I work in the MSR database
group here in building 99 on our group
works on a diverse set of research areas
such as streaming beginner analytics the
key value stores storage security
transactions scale out you name it
everything related to basically the
database platforms recently we have been
open sourcing a lot of the research that
we have been doing in our group and I
wanted to focus on some of these
projects in this talk these are all in
available in github under an MIT license
the first is citral which is the proven
streaming engine that we built here in
the data base group and is now part of
the eternal enterprise organization
it's a streaming engine for real time
and often analytics which I'll talk
about shortly the next piece is
something more recent which we built or
the like last couple of years is faster
it's a fast key value store for
resilient state management and I'll be
focusing today on a little bit more
details about these two water systems
the others that we have also what opens
was recently included as CRA which
stands for a common runtime for
applications CRA is a powerful
distributed runtime for data flow graphs
and it allows you to build distributed
analytics or data flow systems it's
available at this URL and the other
project we've open so recently is
ambrosia which is a highly robust actual
based framework for highly robust
applications and micro-services and
today's focus will be really on the
streaming and state management and you
can talk to a bunch of us who are here
on all of these projects so it's this
includes folks like Kumar Sebastian and
butt guna and a bunch of us are out here
so feel free to talk to us about these
projects so let's start with a brief
description of
so a lot of you may be familiar with
truth from several years back it was a
project that we started way back in 2012
and its goal was to be a streaming
engine for both the cloud and the edge a
lot of scenarios for big data analytics
basically that we were looking at at
across Microsoft drove this project this
includes a very simple real-time
monitoring of applications the exhaust
that is generated by all these cloud
applications and having to raise alerts
when problems are detected the other
kind of use case was the apart from
real-time was they called combination of
real-time with historical where we
wanted to be able to take real-time
streams and correlated with for example
what happens say a week back to detect
anomalies and things like that often
analytics was also very important where
the logs that were being collected in
these data centers had to be either back
had to be useful back testing your
real-time queries or to do analysis or
time series analysis on these offline
logs themselves so there was a need for
an engine that could support all of
these applications and we did still have
several key requirements for an engine
to be handled to handle all of those
kinds of scenarios the first is
performance which is particularly
important for both real-time and offline
right and particular for offline because
you take a large amount of data and you
want to process them until seen maybe
tens of seconds or minutes to be able to
give interactive responses to your
queries at the same time you wanted low
latency for a real-time a fabric and
language integration was the other
requirement which really meant that we
want we wanted to build a streaming
engine as a library that could be
embedded in a variety of distributed
fabrics and this turned out to be a key
reason for drills success where it just
access a library that you can embed for
example in systems like Orleans or a
scope and all of these different kinds
of fabrics as part of the language
equation it's also written in a
high-level language which allows us to
support rich data types and for example
is super important for when you are
performing operations that use a
superset of the sequel data type system
and finally the query model that trill
supports is a superset of sequel it
supports temporal it supports pattern
detection and all of those kinds of
features so basicly trill in terms of
performance it was around two to four
orders of magnitude faster than it's the
delicious steaming engines at that time
and for relational we were able to get
performance it was comparable to the
best columnar database systems at the
time and the way we approach that was by
this notion of having user control
latency specifications so the user says
how much latency they're willing to
tolerate and then we use that to perform
micro batching and colonization and
applying the database techniques within
these micro batches to provide us better
performance and thereby straddle this
latency throughput trade-off we built
well as a high-level language a
component in c-sharp it works at
arbitrary language datatypes and
libraries and the query model was fairly
rich with support for complex windows
pattern detection and pretty much what
you would need in this kinds of
real-time and of and time series
analysis environments so trainers use
across Microsoft including in the SEO
stream analytics service and we have
taught from AC here if you want to talk
more about that service as well and the
key enabler for trill was the
combination of performance the fabric
the language integration in this library
nature and the query model so the
current status is that we have open
source it just couple of months back and
we are actually looking for people for
use cases outside Microsoft to be able
to both use and contribute to the system
the libraries are also available or
nougat which is the package management
system that is used with Visual Studio
it works on botnet core so you're not
really restricted to windows we can use
it on Linux it works on the edge works
on the cloud and it's pretty much a very
kind of reusable component that might be
useful in any form of real-time or
offline time oriented analysis that you
may be interested we've also been doing
work on combining trill with that the
other systems that I mentioned earlier
for example drillbit CRE gives you a
system called quill which is the multi
node streaming analytics system and you
can also you still with some system the
cam proves you have to build real-time
pipelines and it's faster to externalize
your operators state has to disappear in
memory year system so the next project I
want to briefly overview is faster which
is a relatively newer project which
we've been working on is embedded key
value store for state management and the
basic problem
faster addresses is that particularly it
kind of grew out of the our experience
with the tools used in these large-scale
distributed pipelines with managing huge
amounts of State for example in Bing
they have billions of users or ads in
the system which for which you have to
maintain some state and update them as
new what data arrives in the system and
this also includes a stateful
applications such as IOT device tracking
data center monitoring all of them are
super stateful so by state I mean like
you have a large number of independent
objects this could be users in the
system or advertisements in your
pipeline and you have some amount of
state for example this could be a
machine learning model or some
statistics for every single object in
the system
now the aggregate state is so large that
it does not fit in memory and this is
particularly problematic given for edge
or multi-tenant cysts use cases where
you know indexing a huge amount of state
but and you don't want to be you don't
want to provision for the entire state
and the kind of operations that you
perform on this state are very simple
typically it includes point operations
right I mean you just do a hash look up
look up a particular object and maybe do
some operation on it or maybe you
perform an update on the object so you
read the old CPU reading and maybe
increment it and things like that of
course the state needs to be recoverable
there's a particular property that we
can exploit in these kinds of
applications is that even though the
amount of state is large for example in
the search engine you have billions of
users who may be alive in your say seven
day window of data that you are
maintaining but the number of users who
are actively surfing the web or kind of
doing actions at a given point may be a
small fraction so this could be for
example if millions are actively surfing
and being update updating the order
statistics at any given point so we
wanted us a system that could exploit
this this and and reduce the amount of
memory footprint that will be required
to handle the state in these kinds of
applications so faster is the result of
this these requirements and it's a latch
fee concurrent multi-core hash key value
store it's designed for basically I
shared everything
environment where you have a bunch of
threads talking to a shared memory and
having us some kind of backing store in
the end
it's the same for high memory high
performance and scalability across
threads it's a multi-threaded lots free
system it supports data larger than
memory so you can basically are tuned
the the the hot working set and exploit
the temporal locality so that the hot
working set stays in your main memory
and the older data kind of spins off to
a secondary storage or tiered storage
and this could be things like Azure
blobs or a cloud storage in general the
performance is very good when you're
working set fits in memory so for
example if even if the you know indexing
gain allows that memory if you're hot
working set happens to fit in memory we
show that we can actually outperform
pure in-memory data structures like by
by significant numbers and particularly
when you start comparing it with systems
that can handle it a logical memory we
are orders of magnitude better than
those kinds of systems that are out
there today so fun of ICS B workload on
a single machine with high end machine
with two sockets
we're able to able to get around 150 to
200 million operations per second the
interface of faster is consists of both
point reads and blinder bits as I
mentioned but also atomic
read-modify-write operations which are
particularly interesting in streaming
scenarios where you read a value and you
make an update to it so it could be
incrementing a counter or updating some
field in your in your vector of machine
learning model parameters here's a brief
graph of scalability of faster with
respect to number of threads so this
shows that we are faster on the multi
circuit CPU gets pretty much linear
scalability for this by csb workload and
interestingly it's comparable to pure
enemy data structures such as the Intel
TBB hash map which a lot of us are
familiar with and then you compare it to
the today's indexes that are used to
kind of to handle large the memory data
it is significantly better very briefly
I'll kind of geek out on the next couple
of slides on the system architecture
before kind of stepping back and
providing the the current status of the
project so it does a bunch of threads
talking to a hash index in faster and
it's the index is backed by what we call
as a hybrid log which is a log of all
the records that have been that are
being accessed
so the hash index basically contains the
root of essentially a linked list of all
the records that collide to that
location in the hash chain there are
three key technical inhibitions that we
talk about and then the work is the most
president at segment last year and you
can look at it for details yeah so uh
the the inhibitions there are indexing
the record storage and the threading
model so I think these were the kinds of
inhibitions that allowed us to build a
system that can handle data and the
important thing here with the record log
very briefly is that it goes across disk
and the main memory so the hot records
will stay in memory by nichole records
are pushed out to disk a little bit more
briefly in more detail then record-low
consists of a single address space
that's spans both external memory and
main memory and what the record lock
does is that the hot records that are
currently being updated go into the
mutable region of the log which sits in
the tail so you can do in place updates
of those records and as the records
become colder and they age out the end
of the read-only region and you perform
what is known as a read copy update to
bring them back so essentially it's it's
it's a hybrid between the traditional
log structured systems and the pure in
memory systems so I'm going to skip over
some of the technical details and just
talk about the current status of the
system it was open source in August and
it's available in both c-sharp and c++
and it is pretty much in in good in in
good state and we have a lot of
contributors who are also interested in
kind of in providing new features and we
are it's really about if you want to
learn about the the kind of the research
innovations you should look at our
papers and one of the interesting things
we are doing right now is to integrate
faster internal which are now both open
source so to summarize we have recently
open source a bunch of these source
projects and we invite everyone to use
contribute perform follow-up research I
talked to us for more details
thank you
Yan suggests Anna to come up and stand
here
oh and what one is taking questions any
questions yeah so this works on a single
note how does it how does it spread
right so these are components that so be
approached this in a layered approach so
we first build the single node
components in fact a single core
component that we corruption right
sourcing the multi node but we have the
distribution layers that I didn't talk
about in this talk so the the pieces of
CRE and ambrosia are those that take the
singular components unmodified building
blocks and build distributed pipe ends
all of them so all of them are open
source from science University who is
going to talk about democratizing data
Federation for you okay so since
everywhere folk homie
under this special weather condition
this is Gina from Simon Fraser
University in today's talk I'm going to
talk about the three topics and in the
first topic I'm going to briefly
introduce Simon Fraser University data
base and data mining group and the
second one I'm going to talk about my
vision to democratize data preparation
for AI the last part I'm going to talk
about my recent research project called
tar which is happy you to speed updated
data labeling okay so it's a first part
I want to briefly introduce our database
and data mining treatment group we have
been working on this area for over 30
years and we have made a lot of impact
on both education side and also the
intact reset for example we develop a
number of very favorite data mining
algorithm called DB scan and previous
band that is widely used in industry and
we also written test pool coated pit
mining that is also widely in many many
universities in North America and so we
are working on a wide range our research
topics and
we publish papers intensively in data
mining conferences and also database
conferences and I want to particularly
mention our Kim Jong Wong who is sitting
on the back he actually a new faculty
member or drawing our school a few
months ago he's working on clouded
database and also how we can develop a
modern database is amusing new hardware
alright so now I'm going to talk about
my my vision to democratize AI so how
many of you have heard of this phrase ok
so so if you think about democratizing
AI what does it mean that we want to
make AI for the status bar for everyone
okay and you see about that the country
innovation of a AI is really a
combination of computing algorithms and
training data ok and for computing I
think the problem is solved thanks to
all the cloud providers because right
now I can easily teacher and grad
student to launch hundreds of machines
within minutes ok and for every zoom I
think the problem is also kind of solved
because although deep learning is very
hard to use but because of those
software and many many undergrad
students they can write just a few lines
of code to remember very complex deep
learning algorithm to detect objects in
image okay but what about training data
and although there's a few projects that
focus on the training data but I want to
say this part is still the bottleneck
because about three years ago I were the
postdoc in the lab at UC Berkeley and I
read time I heard that my knee they were
sending complaining that I spend more
than 80% time on theta prepare region
well nowadays when I talk with them this
you can tell in that even say oh I spend
even more than 80% I'm on data
preparation I think in order to
democratize
AI we really need to turn our focus on
democratizing data prepare region and
some of when I pretended I hear someone
say always so hard the problem so hard
it's important for you to solve
because symbol that how much time and
how much money
we spent to democratize computing to
democratize algorithm and how much time
and money we spent to democratize data
preparation I think if it's really the
time that we sing hard how to
democratize data preparation for AI I
want to be more precise about what I
mean by data preparation so nowadays
many companies they put all the data you
know centralized place they call the
data lake and they hire a bunch of the
earth scientists hopefully they can't
build some models using the data stored
in data lake and the first step is they
have to generate the training data and
the process of turning the data in the
data lake into the training data which
had the feature at the label it's called
data preparation and so why this problem
is so hot so I remember I had a
conversation with fail who is sitting
here i cider about two years ago and I
asked him that why do you think they
decline e8 very very challenging I think
he said that
oh he think that did cleaning is not a
single problem it's a collection of many
many challenging problems thing about
that data cleaning is address of one
step into the peripheral region which
means that if you really want to solve
the data preparation problem we have to
solve all challenging problems that are
listed here so that's why it makes so
hard to solve the data preparation
problem and some may say that all for
each problem we have already turns out
papers and many many to the many many
algorithm to solve that then what's new
here and in my opinion I think there's
actually the two great opportunities for
database community so one is that in the
past when we divide by a prism we are
focusing on how to reducing the Machine
time but nowadays I think we need to
turn our folks how to reduce the data
same time so imagine we divide by a
besom we need to ask yourself if there's
no such approach or no sir - how much
time that the attendees band to do the
task if they have it who how much time
they spend to do the task if it had
reduced a lot then it's a good rule so
in order to reduce that error that there
anytime we have to make sure our method
is easy to use is extensible and also
has a compute composite composability
property and another grid opportunity I
think we may have is a we have applied
advanced image of learning technologies
so I know there's a talk later how about
the ultimate emotional learning I think
why can't we apply automated machine
learning to solve some challenging data
preparation problem because my needed
problem in date preparation is the
central emotional learning problem we
don't really need their center to review
the entire emotional learning pipeline
to solve our problem and also the meta
learning so because when when I talk
with several banks in Canada so
basically they all want to do the same
thing so they want to build a term
prediction model they want to build a
fraud detection model they want to build
a financial product recommendation model
why can't we leverage is it the effort
that they stand to prepare the data so
that if a new bank want to build rebuild
all the models they have to they don't
have to rebuild they don't have to
rebuild their entire deal preparing
pipeline so I think these are two great
opportunities for data database
community to solve this dinner
preparation our challenge and so in my
lab we have a few projects that in order
to fulfill this vision and last year I
prevent I presented two projects when
the focus on the data enrichment the
other folks on the is brought through
data analysis and today I'm going to
talk about the tarz
which is focused on that did her
labeling part so we know that little
labeling is very very expensive we take
time sing about that how much time we
spend to build an image night and I
think a very promising idea to reduce
the labeling calls it will explore the
trade-off between quality and the human
cost so imagine that I trusted randomly
label the data that I don't have any
human cost but my label are super noisy
is useless if I only asked experts to
label the data then my human culture is
very very high but
my labels of high quality I believe
they're gonna be more and more points in
between for example this in this week's
information is the ideas we have a lot
of people to define some rules so that
they can use a route of magical label
data for example we can see for every
tweet if they have a smiling face inside
then it might be a positive tweet so
that called the rules and when it
applied the rule to the data we label
the data but in a noisy way and another
idea we can use crowdsourcing they are
not as good as experts but they can
actually still provide good or good a
label for us so so then the question is
uh in the future I'm pretty sure they're
gonna be more and more noisy twinning
data and the question is how can we deal
with the noisy training data and so in
fact this problem had been studying the
motion learning community for many many
years so there's a good survey paper so
basically at a high level there's two
ideas so the first idea is we don't do
any data cleaning we just you know we
try to treat all the noisy labels either
ground truth labels hopefully that it's
a model we build can tolerate those
noise because of my emotional learning
models they are very low but they can
tolerate if those noisy labels and
another idea into machine bale cleaning
where we try to build another machine
learning model to predict which instance
training example could have a noisy
labels and and so I have been working on
data cleaning for many many years and I
think that the best way to clean the
data we should look at human in the loop
so I'm thinking that why can't we have a
human in the loop label cleaning so that
human can have her to clean the late
noisy label but of course we have not
had human to clean everything the
question how can we make the best use of
human to clean the noisy labels and our
so with our recent paper tart which is
named after intelligent robot in the
movie interstellar which can always
provide insightful comments to humans
and so at a high level third can provide
hume data scientists who piece out
otherwise so the further what otherwise
they
imagine they have a noisy tighter tater
and they have a model and they want to
know that if I use this noise it has the
data to evaluate the model and how good
my model will be and heard can give the
dentist the estimation of the true
accuracy and also the confidence able to
count if I the uncertainty and the
centerpiece out otherwise Attard can
give their centers to tell their center
how to clean the noisy labels so that
they can improve the model the most and
so due to the time consider I cannot
talk about how we do that in detail but
we have a paper that is online then you
can understand how it works
so in summary or I think democratizing
data preparation for AI is a really
exciting topic and we have as a
community we have a great opportunity to
solve this problem and today we talk
about a tart which is a label cleaning
of the wider to reduce table labeling
cost for AI and some last but not least
we also have two posters from ice are
from my students and one is talking
about how we can use try highlights from
recorded live videos this work is done
by our tumblr the other work is I kind
of related to the keynote but we
actually because psycho is been Asian
had also been widely studied and
nowadays we have the mushroom learning
it's been nation the question is how
different it is to can immerse perinatal
AIDS we have what unified is vanishing
framework so that they're scented can
either is playing a single query all
emotionally model so that is taking the
ongoing work which is collaborating with
you lingual who is the expert in
sequence by nation okay thank you very
much
engineering questions have a question so
if we ask people to kind of help clean
this labeling data how different or
similar is it going to be when we ask
people to for example help clean let's
say you know duplicate data and just
understand you something is duplicate or
is not duplicate is that going to be
similar or same problem or do it's
because of go in the different if you
ask the human to clean the label then
that go is you want to try a better
model but if your argument hood remove
that you click in there going yeah so I
think we thought we had basically we had
defined from micro town and surely this
with humans so that we can label the
days are infinitely by the kind of way
to item shown to the user is different
let me take make it one more question
down on is are you can you are you
that's one of the questions there there
are these other labeling tasks or
ordering suspects to norcombe right that
sort of do like these mini rules or
machine teaches and an example of Danya
how does that work relate to it yes it
was at Magnolia supervision and we
actually don't do anything until they
hopefully into triage attorney model so
that they can tourism authority labels
and we think we are also not because
what if you use know who went over to
the model but you still don't satisfied
with the measuring performance and then
the pregnant can bring human inside to
clean the know it enables so that we can
prove all right thanks again the next
time he threw his woman from from the
University of Victoria and she's going
to talk about influence maximization and
massive crops
first of all let me introduce myself my
name is Diana
Coppola I am a researcher at University
of Victoria Canada I would like to talk
about two of our latest papers one was
published last year in Proceedings of
SSBB M and another one is just submitted
to LGB 2008 19 and we didn't get
acceptance or rejection yet our gosh
doesn't want to thank you I will talk
about influence discovery in graphs in
general then about algorithm scalability
and finally I will tell you about our
algorithmic solution to influence
maximization problem first of all
influence discovery what we want we want
a graph which was given to us to mine it
and discover the most important or
influential nodes for our algorithm it
doesn't matter what exactly phenomena
man-made or natural this graph models
whatever what we get is incidence list
which is a long long list just text
actually and that's about the node ID
and another node ID it's a list of edges
for the graph and from this long long
list which can be received for example
by web browser that goes from page to
page
all those links and produces something
like that without any idea what was
actually written on this page and why
this link is given doesn't matter that's
the input what we want to get is this
meaningful graph structure you can see
in the middle for example what appears
to be the most influential the cluster
actually of the most influential models
most important to some extent we don't
know what importance is actually is but
that's what we are trying to figure out
to compute from the incidence list now I
must tell you that our particular
concern and our particular interest was
to scale up existing method of computing
this importance to massive graphs by
massive I mean with billions of edges
graph that models for example Facebook
or Twitter or constituency of I don't
know United States of America for the
next general election something like
that really massive and to figure out
how we can do meaningful and
theoretically proven guaranteed solution
for the graph structure of that size
that was our thing now scalability just
few words there exist tons of algorithms
that do it that do graph mining and can
figure out most important nodes for
example and what not unfortunately it's
impossible to do in practice because if
graph is massive it will take close to
infinite time plus
limited resources to really do it so
data scientist invent more and more and
more algorithms every year the main
point of them is scalability so that for
example on this laptop I could figure
out from incidents list the structure of
huge graph it's very difficult to do
because we don't even know how to
compare our scalability of different
teams develop different algorithms
written in different languages
implementation and how to do it anyway
recently in 2017 a very interesting
paper was issued we're a team tested 11
the most recognisable and the latest at
that time different influence
maximization algorithms and what they
did they produced the whole tree that
would help customers to pick up this
algorithm or that algorithm depending on
how important for them is in the quality
or memory footprint or time processing
time so now specifically we were working
with from all scalable analytics of
massive graph we were working for
influence maximization problem and every
dimension it what is it given the graph
try to understand the most important
notes the most important the way we
interpret it is the nodes that connected
to the most other nodes it's it's very
easy in Twitter we can kind of
approximate or evaluate or we can kind
of see oh okay this particular person
has 1 million followers it must be very
influential to us this particular person
has 30 million followers and probably
it's the more thing it's true but it's
not exactly true
because in general it's not just your
degree direct connections to those
things but how influential are those are
the nodes and so on theoretical works
two of them they were foundation for our
research one was long ago and second one
it's very interesting
that's Microsoft research team in 2014
they got us patent for this particular
algorithm they suggested a new way of
doing graph mining influence
maximization problem in general can be
formulated as find a given number of
seed nodes such that information would
spread far and wide class in T even for
approximation algorithms randomized
under it we doing randomized what is
different for our approach all previous
teams working on this problem were
focused on cutting the time of
processing because time is enormous even
under on demised algorithms you have to
take so many samples it takes so much
time and so they were trying to do to
cut this time to cut time complexity we
decided because we are data scientists
to get it from a slightly different
approach not to the best of our
knowledge used by any other team before
us and that is to focus on data
structures data structures for small
memory footprint data structures that
would allow us to
first of all load graph into main memory
using just small part of this main
memory and the most important keeping
intermediate result of our sampling into
data structure which again takes very
little memory so we did a lot of
research and there were several papers
but the breakthrough came when we
started using for storing intermediate
result web graph now web graph it's a
compression framework it's developed by
Italian team from Milano and not only
developed it's not just how to compress
the graph it's a lot of different
programs they wrote and they wrote in
Java which was very close to us because
I write in Java 8 it's really easy for
me to understand what exactly they did
and how exactly they did it and this
particular compression allows to up to
10% to get to decrease to go down to add
up to 10% of graph in compressed form
comparatively to the original graph when
we figure out a possibility how to
compress on the flight during
computation during the sampling from
graphs how to do it for intermediate
results that was our big breakthrough
second break through is this idea and
that is our last year paper we call this
algorithm uno singles and that is like
that when you do sampling you do trial
you try to understand how much will
information spread from randomly picked
up node very often in the real world
graph it will spread no
because there is a probability for each
edge and it's never one which totally
corresponds to your life it's never one
even from the most tightly connected
people like one family that exactly
information will spread to everyone know
somebody will not accept it somebody
will be busy with something else and so
on so anyway the idea and this another
breakthrough was why would we store this
particular sampling that can get nowhere
we just picked up node at random we try
to you know spread information no no no
because we randomly picked up the edge
corresponding to the probability given
probability on this edge will it go or
will it not in most cases it won't go so
here's a little bit of statistic how
many in our samples yeah how many those
singles things we found a way keeping
theoretically proven guarantee it was
proved by Microsoft research team
keeping it holding it cut really cut
memory footprint that used by our
algorithm we compared it well I was
working I am working with Japanese
Institute of Informatics professor
Guevara by Asha so they have
supercomputer with Ram one terabyte and
that what we had to use so we could
compare our algorithm with existing
algorithms and of course it's at least
three if not five orders of magnitude
fewer memory used by us now then we a
live
expanded this particular breakthrough I
was talking about and wrote another
paper which is now in well the beam
under review but we already can do
conclusion the choice of data structure
proved to be instrumental in raising
scalability of graph analytics and focus
on not time but space complexity allowed
us to design implement algorithms
processing large graph on this laptop
the biggest one I processed here with
theoretical proven guarantee it was
Arabic which is 640 millions of edges
which is almost billion size graph some
questions any questions just wondering
how did you try to apply that in a
medicine actually it's really
interesting because now I'm working on
new paper and that is identifying case
centers clusters anyway and I am working
with protein to protein interaction
craft right now and yes we are using
those things because when doctorally
actually was presented presenting I was
immediately thinking oh my god they are
trying to understand different factors
and how important they are that's what
I'm doing but I am very no cost purely
mathematical think I don't care what the
graph is but come to think about it yes
the answer is yes absolutely it can be
done and it's very important because if
you can do it on laptop you can imagine
practically
yeah let's let's take it offline because
well just in time yeah I'll break in the
middle in the time all right right right
any any questions I am here all day I am
going back to Canada only tomorrow so
wait our next talk is by Patrick hemic
and from the University of Washington
and she's going to talk about integrity
constraints we business thank you
this is joint work with Dan suture so
I'll start by really informally stating
the problem so we have relation and we
know about integrity constraints and in
this talk we focus on functional
dependencies and multi value
dependencies so in the current setting
either an integrity constraint holds in
the relation or it does not this is
something that is binary but in real
life the data we can think about the
relation almost a meeting the conditions
of an integrity constraint or we can say
that the relation satisfies an integrity
constraint to some degree and basically
we are looking at some type of a
systematic way to relax exact
implication so suppose we have a set of
integrity constraints Sigma and another
one tau and suppose that we know that
this type of implication holds and I
will define what exactly this
implication means formally very soon but
suppose that we have some implications
at holds what can we say about this
implication if the antecedents or those
that are in Sigma hold only to a large
extent not exactly but they hold to a
large extent what can we say about the
extent with which tower holds in the
relation and so and this type of
question has a lot of application in
particular when we want to mind there is
a lot of work on mining approximate
integrity constraints if in a database
instance it is also used for data
cleaning and in the a probabilistic
inference literature
is used for learning the structure of a
ballistic graphical models so in order
to formally define the implication
problem and to formally define what is
relaxation and so on I will introduce
some key concepts and ideas so the first
one is a conditional independence in
probability distributions and they I
will very soon also explain the exact
relationship between integrity
constraints and a conditional
independencies in probability
distributions so we have a probability
distribution over a set of random
variables and we say that a and B are
independent given C if their joint
probability factorizes as you see here
we say that an independent statement is
saturated if it covers all of the
variables in this case all of X and it
is marginal if it is conditioned on the
empty set so now that you know what a
conditional independencies are we can
formally define the conditional
independence implication problem so
assume that Sigma is a set of
conditional independent statements like
those that I showed in the previous
slide and tau is another conditional
independence statement so we said that
tau implies Sigma this is the notation
if for every probability distribution
that satisfies the conditional
independent statements in Sigma it also
has to satisfy a the conditional
independence style and in the late 80s a
Judah pal
came up with this set of a axioms that
you can see there are simple rules for
implying additional conditional
independent statements and showed that
there are sound and that they are
complete for the saturated and marginal
conditional independencies meaning that
if I want that I am capable using just
these just by activating these axioms I
can basically we can basically find all
of the saturated conditional
independencies or marginal dependencies
that hold in the distribution okay so
back to our setting to the database
setting let's say
quick review of functional dependencies
and multivalued dependencies so we said
that the relation satisfies the
functional dependencies a determines B
if for every pair of tuples that agree
on a they also agree on B and embedded
multi-value dependencies like the one
shown here basically holds if a if the
projection on the set of variables in
the independence is exactly it can be
factorized as you can see here you see
the similarity between a probability
distributions the same type some type of
factorization and the multi-value
dependency or an MVD is simply an MPD
that covers all of the attributes and it
is known that we can deter Armstrong's
axioms are sounding complete for a
implying all of the functional
dependencies and Barry's algorithm is
something complete for discovering all
of the MV d's okay so now what is
exactly this relationship between
integrity constraints and conditional
independencies so we can view that a
relation are as an empirical
distribution well each double T has a
probability a uniform probability of 1
over N where n is its the cardinality
and basically what we can see is that if
we have the MVD that given a B and C a
disjoint this B and C factorize
according to what we saw then this
happens the MVD holds in the relation if
and only if B and C are independent
given a in this empirical distribution
so this is the relationship
note that this holds only for envied is
it first for invitees for example a DCM
VD P and C a factorize a holes in this
relation but it is not the case that B
and C are independent in the empirical
distribution this is a easy to see ok so
as I said we want to be able to look at
what we call soft constraints so how
exactly can we quantify the extent with
which and integrity constraint holds in
the relation and we use for this
information theory here are the formulas
they are not particularly important it
stay the most important thing may be to
know this is the mutual information a
hill and to know that all of these terms
are always a positive for every a
probability distribution so for
conditional independencies x and y are
independent given that if and only if
the mutual information the appropriate
mutual information is zero and basically
we will use this mutual information to
quantify the degree of Independence
between x and y given set and it has
been shown already in the eighties by le
that a functional dependency holds in
the relation if and only if the a the
conditional entropy in the empirical
distribution is 0 and then mvd holds in
the relation if and only if there a
appropriate mutual information is zero
in the empirical distribution and it is
worth noting that both that in general
these implication problems both both
four-way databases and for a finding
conditional independencies there are
impossibility results okay so now to the
main result so the relaxation problem is
as follows we have a set of conditional
independencies and we assume that we
know that Sigma implies tell using one
of the known a axiomatic systems and we
want to be able to bound tell in terms
of a sigma and we look at two types of
bounds the first recall relaxation where
we want to a bount out using a linear
positive linear combination of the items
in Sigma this we call relaxation and we
want to see a cases in which we can find
a tighter bound well basically all of
these coefficients are 1 so the first
result is that functional dependencies
that meet unit relaxation basically it
means that if a set of a functional
dependencies imply in another functional
dependency then this also holds in the
soft sense we can really have a good
bound on this implied functional
dependency the extent with which it
holds in the database until you can see
an example these three functional
dependencies implied it abd determine F
and therefore what you see below
is a valid information theoretic
inequality that will hold in every
relation however in the general sense
conditional independencies do not admit
relaxation at all
so in paper by Kassadin or mishchenko
they showed a that this say implication
so this implication always holds but for
any a set of a positive coefficients we
can always find the distribution such
that the mutual information between C
and D is unbounded as a function of
these so we can see that we cannot hope
to have that this relaxation always hold
but in some sense it holds in the limit
because for every given for every
epsilon we can find some set of
coefficients that a can bound it so we
have some a trade-off here in that sense
so this was a relatively negative result
another one that is positive is for
saturated conditional independencies
which are those that actually correspond
to a multi-value dependencies and so
looking at the conditional
independencies we say that x and y are
independent we say the two pairs of
conditional independencies are disjoint
if at least a a one of the following
conditions hold meaning either x and c
the intersection is non-empty or y and z
are non-empty always symmetrically the
other way around and we show and it is
worth noting that all of a Pels axiom
those semi graph with axioms are
basically this joint you always use two
disjoint conditional independencies in
order to imply another one so it is not
so actually this condition can be found
to hold a in practice and basically we
showed that if Sigma is a set of
disjoint conditional independencies and
tau is saturated all corresponds to an
MVD then the implication admits unit
relaxation so in that case we can find
really a very tight bound here's an
example so this is a very simple
example that these two conditional
independencies implied the one that one
in the end and you can see that the
disjoint condition holds because why
appears here is one of the sets that
they are in the conditional independence
and indeed this can be relaxed to this
inequality
so we are capable of bounding the extent
with which that NVD can hold in the
relation using the to use to imply it so
to conclude there is a so the the
connection between integrity constraints
and information theory has been known
for a long time but looking at this
relaxation problem is a is a new problem
really trying to find out the extent
with which and integrity constraints
holds interrelation and there are really
practical
directions to this because they usually
data rarely satisfies constraints really
in a precise manner but only
approximately and so in the main problem
problems here are really finding good
bounds of those coefficients for many
cases so we showed some cases where the
bounds are one we can show that the
bounds we showed that in general the
bounds that there are no bounds the
coefficients can be unbounded for a
different we can look at different sets
of different sets of these conditional
independencies and also there the bounds
are not necessarily one so this is
really a big open problem in this area
any questions so I'm running at this
phone has anything to do with them
that's a good question I am Not sure but
maybe if it has small number of values
then we can use more exhaustive
techniques to to check but in terms of
actually finding a theoretical bound for
the coefficient I'm not I'm not sure
it's a good question so many years ago
when I worked in this general area the
rude question that I never knew how to
answer was what to do about the fact
that these dependencies almost hold but
not quite and I'm really delighted to
see a lot of work that's trying to get
to your last slide says that this is a
potential practical importance I agree
that these constraints that are almost
satisfied are certainly important but
what do I do with this insight you know
now that you've got this axiom at times
then you can solve certain inference
problems how can I use that for example
if you want to decompose a relation and
you say okay and I know I cannot
decompose it I will lose some of the
tuples in the joint but given that you
know that certain integrity constraints
almost holds then you can say okay I'm
going to decompose it I know I will lose
some data but it will not be too much I
can quantify the amount with which it
will lose same goes for learning
probabilistic graphical models you can
assume the independence you say I know I
know it's wrong I know I can they are
not completely independent but they can
still treat them as such I'm willing to
have that arrow so you get an
approximation you get an approximation
to a to the answer yes
awesome thanks again from the University
of Washington and he's going to talk
about machine learning with big clinical
day automating machines
okay so like most of you I'm also a
database PhD but I'm hiding new medical
school so today I'm going to talk about
how to use database techniques to
support machine learning from medical
point of view but the tech techniques I
present all general stuff so you can
also apply them to non-medical data we
all have lots of medical data and
everybody in reticule is talking about
how can we do 3d modeling to build 3d
models to predict patient outcome to
guiding interventions so as computer
scientists we say own machine Ernie's
natural choice so in the medical school
if you come here you will see that her
machine learning is very really used and
almost never deployed in clinical
practice and there are several reasons
behind that I'm going to talk about two
other reasons in this talk so the first
one is that as computer scientists so we
have strong computing expertise so we
know that in order to use machine
learning where we have many machine
learning algorithms we can choose and we
pick one machine learning algorithm and
this machine learning algorithm has many
hyper parameter values like the number
of decision trees in our random forest
so we set those values somewhat
arbitrarily and we use this combination
of machinery Iverson and the hyper
parameter values to build a model at at
the very beginning the model accuracy is
typically low so we have computing
expertise we're changing the machine
learning algorithm are we changing the
hyper parameter values then we repeat a
model
we often do it with hundreds of to
thousands of times we get a model the
accuracy is good enough but this is very
hard for healthcare researchers to do
because they don't have computer
expertise
and second even if we can build a such a
model with high accuracy as we just
talked at the beginning most machinery
new models a black boss
they just don't explain say oh I'll give
you a prediction and say this patient we
have better outcome next year but why
this patient would be having bad outcome
next year we just don't give any
explanation and this is a critical for
clinical practice so now let me go over
those two challenges a little bit more
detail so the first one is really about
model selection and to resolve this
problem computer scientists have started
work on automatic methods to do model
selection in the past few years so the
goal is to help people with a little
computing expertise to do machine
learning Google even released a - called
Google versa
two years ago to help with this process
so it's a commercial product but the
existing methods they cannot handle
large data says if you take a small data
set such as it turns out in the
patient's each patient has 130
attributes you do the search some
automatic model search cowardly takes
several days and if you have millions of
patients each patient has thousands of
attributes that's also common in medical
practice then the search time is
daunting the Google paper showed two
years ago that on scale of Google
datasets it takes half a year to
automatic do model selection for deep
learning for half a year our super large
computer cluster I mean verticals who
are unfortunately we don't have so many
computers so that the situation is even
worse so in order for machine learning
to be widely used in a medical school we
need a automatic of effort completely
automatic because the users don't have
medical our computer expertise and we
also want to do it efficiently on large
datasets and a second even if you can
use a tool to build a highly accurate
model that's still insufficient because
if you don't give explanation say why a
patient will have better outcome next
year the clinicians will not trust your
results they would refuse to use it and
they need boundaries in order to design
tailored interventions and if they get
sued which is
also very common in practice then they
have to defend their decisions in court
and for biomedical research
this can help you will formulate new
theories or hypotheses so most models
are complex you have decision tree with
a few layers that's easy to understand
but a low accuracy you can do deep
learning or support vector machine or
random forest which is complex can give
you high accuracy but if you just use a
single model you cannot achieve goals
both coasts in your teeny asleep we
should typically the case but in the
medical school we want to achieve both
goals concurrently we don't want to
sacrifice even 1% of accuracy because
that's patient's life at the same time
we also want to explain the models
prediction results you know for a
particular patient so that you can be
used in clinical practice so now I'm
going to talk about our work to address
those two problems the first one is
about model seduction so this is the
weak-hearted model selection method
works is called page optimization you
can choose many combinations of machine
learning algorithm and hyper parameter
values you build a regression model
another prediction model to predict the
performance of a particular combination
so you try multiple combinations using
each combination tabular model and an
accuracy you build a regression model
then you use this regression model to
find out the next promising combination
you want to try you would use this
combination the entire dataset to build
a model get an accuracy update your
regression model then you'll eat hurry
to this process typically thousands of
times then you get the final one you
want so this is the state of the art but
he tend to work very well
the problem is that if you have a large
data set it takes a long time for you to
do models or model building on this data
set even once for a single combination
so in the extreme case let's say you
have turns out on the patients each one
has 133 attributes you build an ensemble
model this ensemble model actually wound
one of the major they'll open open data
science competitions our modern server
it takes you two days just to build a
model once and in reality you have many
more fish
many more features and you have a lot of
machinery algorithm a lot of almost
infinite number of hyper parameter value
combinations you want to do the search
that's very slow so how to address this
problem if you just do you know machine
learning way deriving formulas that's
almost hopeless but we are database
people so we can do sampling so that's
the idea you can have multiple sample
sets you start from a small training set
like hundreds or thousands of data
instances that's doable
then you start with our beauty models on
this smaller set then you keep expanding
the training set make it a bigger and
bigger so at the very beginning you have
a very small training set you can afford
to do many thousands of tests in a very
cheap way very fast and most
combinations will just turn out to be
come to here and promising you just
throw them away the otherwise you are
not really sure because you just using a
small sample to test it you're not sure
whether the accuracy you get is the
accuracy that I should be indicator the
combinations performance so what you can
do you narrow down your search space and
you try to expand your training sample
just called progressive sampling shown
in the previous slide you can test the
remaining combinations in a smaller
search space and you can have a further
higher confidence on their capability
and a lot of them will still turn out to
be unnecessary I'm promising throw them
away and you keep doing it again again
so over rounds the training sample
becomes bigger and bigger and a search
space becomes smaller and smaller and
eventually once you narrow down to say 2
or 3 combinations that's not bad you can
even afford to use the entire dataset or
a live sample of the entire data set to
test which one is the one we really want
so this is the idea we try them small to
moderate our size success not after the
Google scale we show that our method can
speed up the process by 28 times and
also within a short amount of time we
can search many more configurations
so we will have better luck in finding a
better combination this will also
improve the models prediction accuracy
it actually cut the prediction area by
11 times 11 percentage so we are faster
we also more accurate if you go to the
data set of Google scale the such speed
improvement will be even bigger because
we start from a fixed size sample which
is independent of the size of entire
dataset so the larger the data set size
the bigger performance advantage remover
have now let's say oh the healthcare
researchers use or automatic a tool to
find a good model with high accuracy but
that's not at the end of it you still
want to explain the models prediction
results and also as we say that we also
want to use interventions if it's not
actionable it's totally useless so how
to achieve both goals
Keamy explanations and suggest
interventions automatically so this is
what we do we already show you that we
want to achieve both hai model accuracy
and we also explain the models
prediction that for every individual
patient if you use a single model it's
very hard to do so the trick we play
here that we use two models concurrently
the first model is the most accurate
model you want you don't sacrifice even
one person of ease accuracy so when a
new patient coming this model make a
prediction with high accuracy don't
touch it
then you have a second model which is
Association rule-based everybody here
knows how Association rule works those
Association rules are mine from
historical patient data set and it's
like a market basket analysis so the
second model is not trying to explain
it's not trying to make predictions
because for this new patient the some
models will say the patient will be at a
good outcome other rules will say the
patient would be a bad outcome so if you
want to resolve the discrepancy is hard
so if you use the second model to make
prediction you will get low accuracy but
the first model already tell you with
high confidence this patient will have a
bad outcome next year so you can throw
away those rules that are applied to
this patient per se this patient will be
a good outcome
throw them away only the other rules
that apply to this patients saying that
this patient will be at a bad outcome
next year only those rules matters and
the issue will give you a reason say why
this patient will be at a better calm
and those of us are all known beforehand
so what you can do is that once you mind
those rules from the historical data set
you can ask clinician to examine those
rules and those rules will give you
hints what kind of interventions can be
applied to those patients so those
interventions can be pre compound
beforehand when a new patient coming you
give explanation at the same time you
suggest interventions automatically so
we achieve both goals concurrently we
cannot do this for every patients
because some patient will have bad
outcome for real reasons but we show
that our data set with 10,000 patients
predicting who will develop type 2
diabetes next year we can do this for a
highly accurate model for 87% of
patients who were correctly predicted by
the highly accurate model to have type
of diabetes next year we can give
explanations say why this patient will
be added that outcome next year so this
is one of the randomly chosen rules just
to give you an idea how it works the
rule says the patient that is using drug
and this drug is used to treat
hypertension and the congestive heart
failure both diseases are known to
correlate with type 2 diabetes and a
second condition the patients in maximum
body mass index is at least 35 if you
have medical background you know that
this means the patient is our piece and
obviously is also known to correlate
which type 2 diabetes so because of
those two reasons we say that's why the
patient will likely to have type 2
diabetes next year and here you already
have an intervention freak umpire for
this rule this intervention say because
the patient is lobby's your so you
should have put a patient into our
weight loss program and in medicine is
known that if you can reduce patient's
weight you can reduce the patient's
likelihood of development have 2
diabetes next year let's know so it's an
effective intervention so we can give me
explanation we can also suggest interval
not automatically thank you very much so
actually you are not trying to say those
explanations are correct because every
patient is different but you just say
those are the possible reasons why this
patient will have bad outcome so
eventually when you do medical practice
each patient has lots of variables they
are scattered on hundreds of pages of
historical medical notes if you ask the
doctor to check all those hundreds of
pages to figure out exactly what are the
reason for example specially you want to
do the count and see how many emergency
room visits the patient coming in the
last three months that's very hard you
only have 15 minutes to do that in
clinical practice but the tool time do
all those analysis beforehand and
present you the candidates those are the
candidates reasons and then the doctor
can check in while minutes say are those
the real reasons and other suggest
interventions although they are pre
compared with our medical knowledge
do they really apply to this vision and
you have to consider the patient's our
personal situation which you cannot hear
from medical record you can only know it
from talking with sedation also common
reasons not to terrorism that's what you
deal with
yes so I think there is one piece of
working this your strip Oei which is
exactly use focus of selection no and we
want to explain later with you both were
sophomores like three years ago we
published it on it yeah yes sir your
results on the on the explanation part
you said you were able to predict 87% is
the reason probably not great 100% that
the results the models different no it's
because I
I think they realize that 14% of
patients they are going to have bad
outcome for rare reasons and those
reasons are not discovered through
associations association rule has
support right so it only cover the
common ones thanks again it's my
pleasure to share my ostrich who share
our work generating application-specific
in memory database so this title is a
little bit broad but actually we are
focusing on one type of application is
there based application with
object-oriented programming interface
because many like database applications
are developed using object-oriented
interface like Java Python or Ruby so
instead of embedding sequel queries in
the program
people usually use object-oriented API
through each search and use the object
relational mapping framework to
translate object queries into sequel
queries and also converts the relational
data back into objects example of such
applications and web applications which
usually use frameworks like hibernate
Django and or Ruby on Rails so we
profile on 12 open source very popular
applications filled with Ruby on Rails
and we are surprising we find that they
are pretty slow so with a small amount
of data usually less than 1 gigabytes in
average over three pages take more than
two seconds to load and most of the slow
pages spend over 80% just choir in the
data so why are this I choir is really
slow even with a small amount of data
and their three major reasons the data
Messick data model and the predicate
involving associate objects and also
program generated predicates but before
I go into the detail of this causes I'll
first give an overview of chestnut also
this is the name of our tool it
generates application specifically in
memory database it's row just it's just
like adding physical designers so it
takes it takes in query workload and a
memory budget so
it customized apparently out such that
the overall query time is minimized but
unlike other physical designers for
relational database this is specific for
database app using object-oriented
program interface and it solves the
issues as we were introduced here
basically it used a different storage
model and used a different way to
generate query plans next I'll go into
the three causes of the slow query the
first is the data model basically the
problem here is the mismatch between how
the application access the data and how
the data is stored and this results in a
very slow data conversion let's take an
example here assume we have a chatting
application and just like slack so you
have channels and activities in the
channel and users so um so the
application manage this data using three
classes the channel class activity and
the user class assume we have a query
that shows the top channels that and for
each channel it includes activities in
the channel and for each activity it
includes the user for a created that
activity so here the object query looks
like this it starts with the top class
Channel and includes activities in each
channel and for each activity it
includes a user so and then do honor and
limit so in order to answer this query
three relational queries are generated
so basically this has three selection
from the three tables the channel table
activity table and the user table and
the result is the three and the result
is three relations but the object query
requires the result of objects so
there's a process to translate this
relational data into object so to do so
the first step is to converge that it's
to go into object and then it inserts
each user into each activity and after
that it's to group the activities by
their channel ID
and then insert activities into each
channels as nested array of objects so
even though the relational query is
finishes really quickly within 1.7
seconds this data did a conversion from
relational data to object data is quite
expensive taking up to 55 seconds so the
bottleneck is likely in the data
conversion so to solve this problem she
has not considered storing data non
relationally it will consider a table
consider a storage way a storage model
that stores the data
next stores the data as a form of object
and a nested object just like this
because the number of activities in each
channel is different so this storage
model is not relational and with this
storage model the data conversion is
only from C++ object to a top level Ruby
objects this is because like the
database it's implemented in C++ and
that this data conversion doesn't change
the structure of objects and it only
takes a one point five seconds to finish
so using this storage model can
accelerate the query by 15 X so suddenly
cause of slow query is the query
predicate involve associated objects so
before so our first show acquire that
doesn't involve associated object so
this is a very simple query that all
that selects an active channels and
order by ID so for this query we can
create a partial index that index only
on active channels with a key of IB
so this is just like a normal partial
index supported by relational database
but what if you change the query to B we
want to select the channels that
contains message activity and also order
by ID
can we still create partial index just
like we did for the first query with a
relational database the answer is no
because most relational database
supports partial pressure partial index
that's the product ID and the key
can only involve the fields that is in
that in the table being indexed so but
here the activities is not part of the
channel so this partial index is not
possible but Krishna chestnut will
consider such index so basically just
not expense the in the other English
syntax by allowing associated objects
fit the field to appear in the keys and
the predicate for example it can create
index on channel ID that contain message
activity or it can also create an index
on channels with the key being the
activity ID the third problem for soccer
is a program generated query predicate
because in this object-oriented database
applications usually the partial
predicates are defined in multiple
functions and at runtime the function
calls are chained to produce the final
and final query predicate so in this
case curve of predicates are usually
contain overlapping and the redundant
particular predicate and in this case a
relational query optimizer have a hard
time finding the optimized query plan so
let's see an example for example we have
a page web page showing join or leave
activities which are also non message
activities that created or updated
recently so the query is like this we
have the predicate says like type is not
message and the type is join only and
the created or updated a larger than a
certain time so assume we have two
indexes available the first thing that
is create is a composite index created
on field type and created and the second
index is also composing index and type
and updated so we give this a query to
post grass and can you guess whether
like it will find a plan to use this to
index on that because it seemingly it
can use that index to answer this query
so the answer is actually no if you give
this query to
Postgres it will actually generate a
sequential scan plan which takes 2.0 2.6
seconds to finish but actually we had
noticed that here the type not you go to
message it's hell actually a redundant
predicate so what if we rewrite it into
an equivalent query that remove the
redundant predicate and at this time
host Kratz can generate a plane that
indeed use this to index and the Jen and
this plane that using the index tag only
no point five seconds to finish so this
means that the first occur we can
actually leverage the index but the
existing query optimizer is not able to
do that because of the redundant
predicate so this is because most most
of the time the query optimizer used two
rules you should feel like absolute to
rewrite require a decade and it
determine what index you use and how to
use it but instead just not use a
different approach it you numerous plans
from a small size plan to large size
plan so the plans so small size plan
just like the first one is adjust an
index scan and it will enumerate many
different plans with different
parameters passed through this skin from
it will also enumerate from small size
to larger size for example on the bottom
it has a the news plan has a four index
skin and then Union the result so it
will enumerate many implants and
apparently in this step many planets are
actually invalid it cannot answer the
query so just not use a very program
verification to verify whether the plan
is valid or not basically it use
symbolic execution so symbolic execution
is a process where you create symbolic
tables the tables have symbolic values
instead of concrete values so when you
run the query on a symbolic table you
get an expression and when you run the
query plan you get another expression so
it use a solver to check whether these
two expressions are equivalent or not
and all possible values of symbolic
tables if yes then the plane is valid so
basically it is able to tell that the
first plan using only one index current
index can cannot answer the query it's
not it's an incorrect plan but the
second is of course we can see that this
enumeration process is slower than
existing query optimizers but it is able
to find out a good plan for example the
plan that use the index even for the car
is set containing the redundant
predicate but open this I this is slower
than if this inquiry optimizers but it
is tolerable as long as this optimizer
runs offline and the chestnut is an
offline and physical designer so here's
this figure shows the workflow of
chestnut it takes in the query workload
and a memory budget so first it
enumerates plans and storage models and
the plans for each query and then it use
some heuristic to prune to prune the
plans and after that it formulates the
problem of the physical design into an
integer linear programming problem
basically the constraints are first each
query uses some data structures and the
second that use the data structures is
within the memory budget and the goal is
to minimize the overall query time so it
uses an external solver to solve this
IOP problem and the result tells which
storage model it uses and what was
planned and every query uses so based on
based on the result it generates C++
code and this code implements and
emember a database engine that is
designed specifically for this workload
so now I should evaluate we evaluated
our three open source web applications
and we compare against the three in
memory database engines including the
original application setting which uses
my sequel and Postgres but we use an
automatic index index ER to fill in the
missing index that may not have been
created by the original pro our original
application and we also use used hyper
with automatic in desert as a baseline
so this shows like the average query
time of these three applications
so we showed the relative time to the
origin also it means that the shorter
slow shorter bars are better so we can
see here a plan that generator page has
not has much shorter query time than the
other than the other databases and the
number here on the top shows the speed
up against the hyper which gives the
best performance among all the
relational databases and note that here
the shaded area shows the portion of
data conversion means converting from
related from relational data into
objects and that this portion actually
takes takes a big unpicked a large
amount of the query time and just not
you because is used a different storage
model it can significantly accelerate
this part and for all of these three
applications is and it in Chestnut is
able to find or to generate the database
within one hour to conclude we are we
introduce a tool chestnut that generates
in-memory application specific database
which takes in a workload and a memory
budget and optimizing the over on and
customize the data layout to optimize
the overall query performance it uses a
non-relational storage model which
source data as objects and nested
objects and it extends that thing impact
indexing tax and user since it says I
think this is based applying enumeration
to be able to find good plans even if
redundant or overlapping query
predicates are involved and we show that
it achieves significant speed up in real
word web applications Thanks
[Music]
any questions
how do you handle the evolution
of the work Road what I mean so
currently is a static process because we
take the application assume we can get
the source code of the application so we
analyzed source code and then collect
all the queries so we do not handle like
dynamically changing workflows
so it's an offline static analysis but
even then like let's say your
application is also evolving right then
you have to like rewound because it's a
in memory data memory database so you
can if the application involved in you
have rerun the tool and then generate a
new database because the new database
will load the data from it also have
used some relational database as a
back-end but that only just persist in
the data without answering the query so
you have rebuild an in-memory database
by loading the data from the new it can
but on that right I'm sorry the quads
I'm not sure I understand it correctly
but your question is like if you have
already have a like a post-grad database
can chestnut translates a query into the
civil power and an issue to the Postgres
chestnut chestnut is a query system
where the databases it's a therapist so
it handles all the query from the
application but only holds the data in
memory so it still needs a back-end
storage to use to persist all the data
to make sure your data is not lost but
it kind of like serve as a middle middle
chair that the query it answers all the
car is much faster so the if you have
like a read query you don't need to go
through the backend database so it hold
it's just like a way to how
the data in memory but store it in a
different form in a different form that
such that the data can answer the query
more efficiently I understand I'm just
wondering that if we do have a database
right now in focus and we want translate
it into a way where we could query so
much faster using chestnut be able to
translate that or make up some database
or we are not reading the query to the
backend database so we assume that we
are the workout has all the cars and
like we can answer all the parts using
[Music]
pick on because if you have like an
unseen power that it's not a part of the
workload and then going it will go to
the backend database last question how
to actually be one honest the last 15
you talk about the index and slides 15
oh yeah just one this query and the
first one is that whose quest then they
use index you know why another people
you have the sauce colored yeah so I
guess I try to so this is it like a hard
question I tried to read the post grad
school or school but it's too
complicated for me to understand so I
tried different ways and it turns out
that is the cardinality estimation that
has a problem so it will search for like
in the user plan to you it will like yum
final planet use the index but because
of this redundant predicate it greatly
affects the Cardinal the cost estimation
and it determines that with the index
the cost is very large so it is her
misuse of sequential scan so I don't
know exactly how it was through the
estimation so and I believe it I know
they can use index but it's kind of hard
I mean a lot of potato I know they can
use index this query but the
this one even discussed it offline so
it's a good question so I think all the
speakers will be available now during
lunch we'll have now full stress session
doing lunch as well phil has a bunch of
logistics emails but not much not much
really the lunches lunches out back
we're supposed to be but we want to stay
on schedule and get out early then we
should be back when 1:15 and the in
addition to all the drinks out there
there's also if you go through these
doors into the end there's there's a
refrigerator full of soft drinks and
other things to drink the afternoon
please come up here and sign there a
video release form already check that
your laptop works